[Music]
welcome back
to another episode of the careful boys
here featuring
hot seat with mr ryan man everybody oh
wait no there's only one way to do
hunting
it's a news segment sponsored by
t-mobile
this is really sponsored yeah it's by
t-mobile
my [ __ ] games
wow okay look at this look at this
sponsored by game of thrones no we just
like
getting built by the mayor of monterey
park i don't know what's gonna happen so
if you guys are new to hot seat what we
do is it the seat starts kind of cold
and cool we ask questions to get to know
you and then we start turning up the
heat and then we get to know you a
little bit better this gets hotter cause
we turn up the heat
that's a knob go ahead bars
[Laughter]
what's your five-year plan
five-year plan why are you laughing at
me oh you whispered you [ __ ] court
jester my five-year plan damn that's a
big ass question i i know one thing i
want to do in five years you get mollied
i want to get my car back
where is it i had to sell at the
no i had a 79 camaro that uh it got
flagged for smog oh [ __ ] california i
know it's [ __ ] up so they made me uh
get rid of it so i sold it to a dude in
arizona and i just someday want to get
it back the exact car i would love to
get or any 79 or just something close
but
i mean like a 99
i think i can help you with that
you know next best thing you don't want
the same car you don't want to hit up
the same guy and be like yo you want to
sell it back to me i would love to yeah
but then i don't know how i'm going to
keep it here i know how
i'll tell you how after
yeah oh [ __ ] i mean wait a minute hot
seat for joe wait what are you talking
about joe's our smog guy
that's your thing you look like mine i
know certain places yeah i was cheating
smog for like 10 years and then but the
sad part it's like the cops in my
freaking neighborhood know yeah so if
they see me in it again the dude is like
if i even see you with this he knows
i've been skirting around the yeah it's
like one of those shits you've got to
stop doing donuts in your neighborhood
that's the sad part is i was just going
like i was going normal down the road
normal donuts hate her ass [ __ ] it felt
like i was like you know one of those
like old movies where someone's in the
south and like open the hood boy it was
like one of them [ __ ] i was like damn in
hollywood
yeah yeah if you had a prius it like let
them gab
it changes the car yeah the cops are
different over there
yeah breeze what's this gas guzzler
doing here
in five years i don't have very deep
plans but that's one thing i i still
have on my mind it's gay bars rewind the
whole episode by itself by the way let's
go with your hollywood cop
character sponsored by t-mobile
sponsored by the marvel cinematic
universe all he would use his own
superhero
let's rewind a bit for those who don't
know who you are
you basically um came into this world as
a quest member
into this world of entertainment right
yeah dance crew dance crew where you
guys won the america's best dance group
and ken just was number two right but
then like we're not talking about
kendricks today we're talking about
quest today yeah we're not talking about
number two you can just talk about
number one question into this dream of
becoming a dancer a quest dance member
for dance
very simply
i was going to community college
uh cypress college you know and then
i honestly we would just see all these
girls walk to the um other side of the
campus like at the end of the day all
the time we're like wow this girl's
going back there and then we went and it
was like a dance class
and then uh me and eris were like yo
let's join this [ __ ] class and all
the girls are here who was teaching it
just like these random faculty like
dancers that were i mean they were just
like
i don't know they're like just a little
bit older than us the teachers and then
uh i signed up for like everything like
for modern for uh
jazz and hip-hop because i just wanted
to be around like these are like the
hottest girls in the community college
that's really toxic actually and then i
remembered i once it started
like i had this mission to like get to
know these girls and then i was like yo
the actual class is pretty fun so you
started falling with the dance more than
the girls yeah literally we were just
like yo did we forget the [ __ ]
mission here and then we just fell in
love with just wait you so you never saw
a story until college i i started i was
breaking like in high school like but
just watching [ __ ] soul train like
nothing serious like from 16.
but then i never i never took a dance
class until 20 i think 20 yeah 20 21.
could you do windmills before in high
school flares yeah but it took me two
years because i
usually i think it takes people like a
few months to learn windmills it took me
two years then you kept at it
what's a win
what's a windmill friends you go like
this and then you you you are here and
then your rolls off your shoulder and
you your legs are like a windmill like
this dude they showed me a video of you
like jumping on your own [ __ ] head
you landing on your head that [ __ ] was
crazy i want to turn that into an nft
one day i want to i want to do turn the
last time i do it into an nft why don't
you do it right now a little bit no
don't do it anymore don't risk it
dude
how did that feel when you landed not
here at least i did it that one started
as an accident because uh it was like a
common sort of common move to do it like
this it just bounced like a back
handspring yeah and then um it was uh
it was all all you see
all you see was the name of this one
like competition where was all the uc
schools going against each other the
chinese associations from like usc ucla
uci and celebrate that chinese dance
crew he was there it was like 2005
i went there to do an exhibition uh show
with my crew at the time called six step
and i was practicing that movie you just
go bounce on your head and then you
stand like super quick
and then uh there's girl i was trying to
date and she was there all women
motivated yeah and i was just like yo
i'm gonna kill it it was [ __ ] cheryl
and then uh i went to do that move and
it was at union station where the the
floor is pretty slippery it's like that
tile [ __ ] so i slipped and i just went
like that and then everyone went yeah
and then i just like uh i stuck it and i
remember i made eye contact with her and
i was just like
you're like you had a whole neck boner
yeah
that's the movie moment where you're
like oh my god i can't believe i did it
and you didn't even break your neck did
you get the kiss bro did you get the
kids did she like you after that yeah
yeah we dated like i had a very toxic
relationship after that and then i
[ __ ] it's so funny when guys are like
she's my [ __ ] trophy and then you get
it you're like oh i don't even watch
this anymore i never want to get the
girl that way so after i came up from it
people were like yo you did that new
that move and i was like yeah yeah i was
i was working on that like
when you talked to her was she like
nice moves yeah it was like the
stereotypical stupid [ __ ] like meanwhile
he's got like blood coming down like
meanwhile my brain cells are i don't
even [ __ ] know my name
but yeah that's that's how i came up
with that and then i started trying to
do it on purpose that way because i was
like oh it didn't feel like much because
anthony told us the backstory and we
were all amazed about i forgot what show
was so you think you can dance so you
think you dance you're about to be
eliminated or something and then that
was your clutch final moment and before
that you weren't able to hit it and you
[ __ ] landed it
right was that like a elimination round
type thing where you had to solo out of
nowhere and you [ __ ] stuck the [ __ ]
out of that yeah that's that's one of
the best sticks i ever had of that [ __ ]
i wasn't bragging about you i'm not a
fan of that that's wild man that's a
[ __ ] neck breaking move yeah that
[ __ ] but it's funny because i've never
had one thing go wrong from that oh my
ever like out of the hundreds and
hundreds i worked a [ __ ] uh show in
malaysia i got on this like one job
where i had to perform at this mall
like five times a day and they would
specifically ask me to do that over and
over and i must have did them maybe 40
times a day or some [ __ ] nothing
happened nothing happened nothing you
got a thick neck bro then i went up for
a layup rolled my ankle
[ __ ] like that that's the kind of person
i'm offering he's like yeah i don't know
how to read anymore though
i forgot
yeah this is gone now my ability to keep
reading i heard but i've got i had brain
damage from other moves like like what
from this other one that like it's just
like a
you ever seen the party rock anthem
music video with elementary what do you
call that move by the way it's almost
like you're tr a failed backflip it's
it's just a gigantic like leap of faith
onto your like smaller your background
it's the party rock
everyone's shuffling all over town yeah
yeah yeah i watched that the other day
yeah so that specific move
gave me like the worst concussions in my
life and like short-term memory loss how
many times did you do it i've done it
probably as much as head the head [ __ ]
oh yeah but that one i had to do like
because it was in so many shows and then
sometimes the uh the stages wouldn't be
ideal like because since that was in
that song every time lmf would perform
that song and that part comes up i would
have to you know do that and when you do
it is it one of those like while you're
mid-dancing you're like oh [ __ ] here
comes the thing i have to do it was for
a little bit yeah cause you because the
more you you know the you just become
autopilot so like the more you do the
same show over and over things like that
are not gonna give you adrenaline
anymore your dancing name should have
been collateral damage
there was a time in when the speak there
was like a stage i was so narrow
and this the speaker monitor was so
close that i got claustrophobic and the
worst thing you can do when you fall
back like that is to not put your head
forward at the right minute because if
you or moment because if you don't you
hit the back
and then uh that's where you can really
like shake your whole [ __ ] brain
and i've had like whole like entire 24
hour periods where i had no uh
i had short-term memory loss like i
would just keep repeating myself because
i couldn't [ __ ] like uh old lady with
alzheimer's and [ __ ] yeah holy [ __ ] how
many concussions have you had do you
think i've had five five that was
serious like that we should be called
concussion boys
instead of careful boys
maybe that's why we should be called
careful boys your mind now bro yeah but
yeah that's that's a that's why i kind
of stopped doing crazy [ __ ] like that
because
that's what we call this [ __ ]
sacrificial style yeah it is after a
while i started to have the same effect
as if i did get concussion but i wasn't
doing [ __ ] i would just be sitting there
and then i would just go ah [ __ ] like i
could feel it trigger
and then for for at least 24 hours i
have no memory of what the [ __ ]
happening when you go to the jesus when
you go to the doctor you he's like yeah
so what are you doing he's like yeah i i
jump on my head
every single day five times it's funny
because they'll ask you that question
whether you're checking your head or
your dick like they're gonna go what do
you do are they connected to that
somehow jeez but yeah that's the
freaking uh when i did get a cat scan
they looked at the back of my skull and
they said there's a calcium deposit that
makes it look like i'm wearing a knee
pad on the back holy [ __ ] i guess it's
from like hitting it that it like gets
thicker you know you have one up here
too for my head spins no i don't have
one isn't that on your elbow though yeah
i have i have them both in my elbows
because you land on them too all the
time that was way like 10 years before
he also does [ __ ] crazy i would
always bend 90s on his elbow and then i
got a what's it called it would get
swollen like this big and then because i
didn't want you know i didn't have the
insurance or money or anything to fix it
i would just hide it i would wrap it up
and i would watch tv that night like
this for hours until it like goes down
and then a year later i got in a car
accident where they were like um trying
to draw blood and then they pulled out
the it was all white
in the syringe oh my god and we're like
this guy's a white walker it was
what is that is that puss or yeah it's
like it's the build up from like all of
the i guess like because the doctor just
was like did you tear your ligaments at
some point because there's a lot of
stuff in there and we can't get the
blood like they tried multiple times and
just white [ __ ] white [ __ ] over and over
and then um
and then because they did that the guy
was the doctor was like oh it's probably
gonna heal weird now
uh you're probably gonna have like a
shell type calcium redeposit
and then since then like literally like
i have like no feeling on the tip of my
head you're strong you can just elbow
the [ __ ] out of people yeah dude you're
a superhero you should do muay thai dude
yeah
this is what i was trying to explain to
silent mic when i was like dancers are
athletes but he wasn't
[Laughter]
uh so we've reached the 12 minute and 58
second mark which is the part of the
show where we like to take it down a
little bit and get emotional like to
open it up and get emotional now and get
real really what happens for hot seats
yeah 12 58 i always talk about we're not
talking about break dancing no more and
they call it that because obviously you
break your body
so um can you tell us about part of your
a time in your life when you struggle
personally and you how you persevered
yeah um it's like a job interview
question right there bro
the only thing i think of course like
with most people is like when something
challenges you uh and it gives you an
identity crisis and that was when i tore
my uh acl on my knee live on stage
during a concert oh my god was it an
lmfao concert yeah it's all in footage
too it's slow-mo high like screaming and
you're and you're holding on to your
knee like you're like party walking in
the ah tonight and then you fell down
i wish it was that [ __ ] cool but
there was a there i was subbing
basically because steve was uh steve
terrada is the flips guy in our team and
he wasn't on this tour yeah so we would
do this thing where a guy would do a
backflip and someone on the side would
just shove him in the air and then the
back people go sideways over two people
and i'm not normally the guy that does
that but i had to just be the guy i'm
kind of like the next person that could
do it and my legs are just not uh for
that so
after every show like it would just kind
of like wear away yeah because when
you're landing lateral your uh your
knees just doing this
and so every time you did do it you can
feel that i feel it getting a little
loose yeah and then uh
by the i think it was like maybe the
ninth or tenth show
uh
i did it and then right when i landed it
but you just see my knee totally like do
this and come back
and then you show the viv
and then um and then i stand there and
it's at the last [ __ ] pose yeah so i
have to just hold it stuck it yeah land
it hold it with his tears coming down
you're going
and then everyone in the audience don't
know they're like oh my god that's
[ __ ] amazing that second one yeah you
could see my face like i knew that i
[ __ ] it up like 100.
[Music]
wow
zoomed in on your face
it's our camera dude that's like our
homie did he know yeah he knew because
you feel things like snap because
sometimes the tendon will like block
above even as noisy as it was i could
hear it clearly yeah it's all got some
joggers on too yeah it must be one of
those things where you like something
like that happens in your body and it
just like echoes into your like because
i heard it's so loud yeah and then i was
just standing there going like oh [ __ ]
and then i still have to come back out
and like play because i also did
keyboards so i didn't think it was
anyone else
dude you do everything yeah so i i
became just full-time keyboardist for
the tour after that happened like i
couldn't dance anymore and that was the
biggest like i think the only time ever
in life i was like really you're like
i'm meant for dance not for this
keyboard [ __ ] i'm supposed to be a
flip pusher
because i never had one injury until
that like everything's everything that's
happening has been comical but like that
was like a real [ __ ] injury like that
acl tear was that the biggest injury
you've like had in your whole career i
would say yeah it's a bit most
debilitating because i couldn't dance
for
almost a year how was rehab on that uh
it sucks because um
that specific knee was i'd stretched it
over the course of so many years in
order to like do flexible tricks i used
to be able to put this foot on that side
of my head yeah i've seen you do that
and that's crazy yeah and now i can i
can barely even hold it this far so but
it used to go all the way over here so
when your identity is this like
dancing guy that's flexible and all that
stuff and you can't do the things that
you worked so hard to do how did that
affect you i just didn't know i was just
like you know what to do what am i then
yeah i mean you're a musician now at
least you have that to fall back on that
was nice but like everybody's fallback
plan you never want to actually fall
back into it
like you'd rather make it feel like i
decided to do it and not like you're
forced there or falling back onto my
fallback like kind of [ __ ] sucks did
you think in that moment like i'm never
gonna dance again guilty feat of god no
[ __ ] i'm sorry it was too easy i did i
didn't i just i knew that like i think
the worst part is that we were in the
middle of a tour so it's like if you get
hurt and you can't do something like
okay you can't go to rehearsal you can't
do stuff but like we were in the middle
of like a big big contract so it was
like i felt like i was also abandoning
like
my responsibility of you know were you
like [ __ ] steve
no but steve was [ __ ] up too because
that around that same time was when he
broke his neck and like broke two
vertebrae on the movie he did you guys
are real athletes there's not very many
dancers i think that are real athletes
but you guys definitely are the real
ones well that's that's also a part
that's hard because like a point of
pride
of my identity was that i was like
unbreakable you know like
like my i love that rep you know like oh
this dude never gets hurt so like when
that happened like even though like to
some people saying it's kind of like a
funny thing but i used to really like
since i was a kid had that reputation
even in school of like yo this dude that
feels no pain he just can jump off this
[ __ ] and die
he could die
it was like you're never injured right
you're never scared until you feel the
pain and you don't want to go through it
again and then that's just where it was
like a reality check like bro you can't
[ __ ] no matter how much you work out
or do anything you're not gonna make
your tendons buffer you know like you're
not gonna make your acl like you know
it's just gonna stay exactly what it is
but for all your
like dances that you've done and all the
crazy [ __ ] you've done the fact that
you've only
had like a handful of [ __ ]
concussions and acl tears that's not
that's not bad yeah it's not i mean it's
not too shabby but yeah definitely that
was the one period where like when
you're forced to just sit out and then
watch everybody else like go off and do
their thing and you're just like
yeah but at least you you you won so
much like you did so much like this guy
came in second place like it's like
[ __ ] dude
that's just a different thing like you
can step away from dancing and be like
yeah i [ __ ] did it you know i mean
like that's true because you even have a
dope ass music fall back like what does
anthony got dude i don't know jay kate
diggles or something he's got this yeah
yeah god that shirt's pretty [ __ ]
cool is that new i just love seeing the
back of his head whenever you're talking
i can't see his face my [ __ ] no all
right uh last question oh we're still
going yeah last question
i think he's about to turn this camera
off
and it'll turn off the heat a little bit
because i don't think we're that hot on
either that's true who is the shadiest
dancer you know
shadiest [ __ ]
yeah like you would be like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] yeah the crew the whole
this was the wild wild west this dancer
would be in the wanted poster yeah like
i don't even know this dude but if you
don't like them i'll [ __ ] i'll jump
them with you dude there's a bounty on
his head who doesn't dance by the rules
exactly i don't i don't even know who's
the nancy kerrigan of dance yeah who's
the biggest offender of dance oh there's
nothing it's hard to [ __ ] say nancy
was really nice oh who's the other what
does margaret play tanya harding tanya
harding
i was like wait a minute she was the
good one
[Laughter]
damn i don't know i guess like there's a
couple of people that [ __ ] got called
out for the me too [ __ ] last year
oh oh
yeah like predators i wasn't in people
that are like mentor roles and stuff
like that in studios or dance team
captains or leaders that like use their
power plays and stuff like that as like
the choreographers or directors of their
teams let's let's let's let's list them
up man come on dude that's that's the
hard part is that like
i don't know man like until like i'm a
victim of i've never actually been a
victim of any malicious dance
related [ __ ] but i've heard of it and
seen it
uh
so i can't i don't know i can't even
really speak on ryan's also a nice guy
in our scene in the community everybody
loves him yeah who doesn't like ryan
heard of like
yeah it's usually the one that's
probably people don't like for something
i did
you never see people like steal someone
else's dancing shoes or something like
they do or no before before an intense
competition they tyler shoot the other
team's shoelaces oh [ __ ] dude it's a
disaster
are you kidding me this is
sabotage like farting someone's masks
and they have to put it on that's some
[ __ ] that would happen within the crew
to remember the members yeah
backstabbers dude backstabbers i can't i
mean i just i don't think
there's it's like more of like maybe
there's been organizers or people that
are
um that you work for in dance that would
be [ __ ] up but like dance for the
dancer i don't know if any like
unless you do and i'm forgetting this
isn't my hot suit dog
[Laughter]
i just don't i don't have experiences
like that with other dancers other than
like uh
i don't know people that like didn't
like quest for some reason was there
like a 911 of dance god where everyone's
in the dance community is like yeah man
that's [ __ ] oh that's yours oh [ __ ] yeah
that changed everything i remember where
i was yeah
when [ __ ] finding neverland came out
and everyone who started dancing because
of michael jackson just like stayed
silent for a second yeah they know how
to feel it oh
right because like that was very dance
dancer-based community because of
cypress college yeah
but everything is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you